FORMER PRESI TLD RALLY
TONIGHT.
S, INDEED,T IS THEFO
HE COULD BE DAYSWAY FROM
IRST FORMER
PRESIDTO.
CONTINUE, HTHIS C
HIS LAWYER SAYINTI B INVESGAS AA
EG AFFAIR.AEL YS H TPAYOFF AS  D
TESTY BEFORE TAND SH
"O D AOU
THAT'ST DISCLOSUREED BEFORE THAT
T BUT  IS AST A MATTER
IF, IT IS A MATTEN TRUMP
FOR D.ISS BEEN OUT T
ABSOLUTELY.O D IS IWE?
T'S A SOLILLD TECHNICALLY.
BRG E YEARK E CASE SHOULD'VETER
IMMUNITY AS PRESIDENT RED.
ITHOBROUGHT
HIS OWN CAMPAIGN THROU WM COHEN
DIDN'T DISCLOSE IT.
AND THAT'S A VIOLATION O
>> SO, TO TALK ABOUT THES LAWYE.
AND BVIOUSLY TRYING TOKENTELIEV
THIS TIMIN P
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S BECAUSEEADE
LIFEUSINESS LIFE FS TO T SOMETH.
>> TO URVEY DONE, MAYBE.
ESG
ERE?
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S LEL
OT CASE ON
THE MERITS ON THE LAINIF THEY'R
M ONAUSE  PROSECUTORS ARE Y MP
ANR SOME REASON MAEY'T WANT TOO
CD THISMAYBE THERE  ST WEOWD T
EQUATIORHEM.
WE DIDN'T  MONTHS, FOR
STONEWALLING THE GOVERNMENT NGE.
>> SO WE DON'T S HEARD THAT TRU
HE CHANCE., I DON'INO ANYBODY TH
IF YOU WS LA, WOULD DVISED HIM T
OR DID HE  T THING?
PRRILDETONSSNATION.EMBER THFIRSE
E DISCUSSION ABOUTLAWYERD TO PR
BE M
SAYING RIGHT.E CLOSING LINEE
WAS TRUMP'S OWN LAWYG  A
BUT OBVIOUY YOU'VE GOT FULTON U
YOU'VE GOT CE'S ALSO SCIVI
YORK.
A FORMER PRESIDENT HAS  INDICTEE
THING.
ASK Y WHICHU THINK THAT I
STOP HIM OR DEHIM?N WHY
WOULD IMCT ACTUALL
>> NO.
>> SY NO?CA
IF EGAL AENWOULTHAT THEY'VEO SP.
I DOHI GNGN
AND MAKE A BIGSS
L TROUBLES TY ATPERSECUTED.
ARENGEY ARE
PERSECUTING ME,
DANIELS.Y,LY JAN 6T WAS YOUR FLM